- [Announcer] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(light upbeat music)
- Well good afternoon, everybody.
For those who don't know
me, I'm Fiona Doyle,
and I am the Dean of
the Graduate Division.
It's my great pleasure to welcome you
to the second lecture of the HarvEst
Distinguished Women Lecture Series.
For those who don't know,
the Graduate Division
has a proud tradition
of managing the Berkeley
Graduate lectures.
We now have eight lectureships,
each with a distinct endowment history.
These unique lectureship programs
have brought distinguished
visitors to Berkeley since,
believe it or not, 1904,
so this is a long standing traditions,
to speak on a wide range of topics,
ranging from philosophy, to sciences,
with an awful lot in between.
We've hosted dignitaries, Nobel laureates,
and many hundreds of
globally renowned thinkers
whose ideas have a world
changing influence.
The HarvEst lectures
are the newest addition
to this stellar collection,
and I'm convinced that they will have
a similar impact to some of the others.
The HarvEst Distinguished
Women Lecture Series
features women from a broad range
of disciplines and cultures.
It offers a forum to
foster thoughtful dialogue,
and an opportunity to be inspired
by outstanding and
accomplished women leaders.
Today's lecturer, as you will hear,
certainly fits this mold.
Professor Laura Tyson is remarkable
for her accomplishments and impact,
not just in academia, but
also in public service.
The inaugural lecture
in the HarvEst Series
was presented by Harriet
Fulbright in October of 2013.
And like our event today,
was convened here at International House.
This is the perfect setting for dialogue
centered on shaping a world
of greater understanding,
and where diversity of
perspective is welcome.
But also, International House is a place
where individuals are
encouraged to dream big
and see that they can
truly change the world.
The HarvEst name originates from combining
the first names of our
lecture benefactors.
UC Berkeley alumni couple,
Harvey Lee, of '88,
and Esther Ma, '87, both of Hong Kong.
I'm delighted to say
that Esther and Harvey
are here today with us,
along with several of
their family members.
So if you get a chance,
do give them a warm
welcome back to Berkeley.
(applause)
It's now my pleasure to invite Esther
to the lectern for a few minutes
to talk about her vision
in establishing this lecture series,
and then I'll come and
introduce the lecturer.
Esther.
(applause)
Welcome.
- Thanks.
Thank you, Dean Doyle.
Good afternoon ladies and gentlemen,
students and faculty.
Well, happy belated Valentine's Day,
and Happy pre-Chinese New Year of the Ram.
(speaks Chinese)
So this is how the HarvEst story goes.
In 1985, on a sunny
day by the Sather Gate,
two Berkeley freshmen from
Hong Kong met by fate.
Harvey and Esther, or
when the names combine,
better known as HarvEst,
were passionate about studying economics.
Harvey took Econ 1 from
Professor Laura Tyson,
while Esther got Professor Freeman.
And before you knew it,
the HarvEst seed was sown
and started to blossom in Wheeler Hall.
So today, 30 years later,
HarvEst returns to Cal,
with their little HarvEst, Kisha and Tika,
to celebrate the 1985 vintage.
But more importantly, to pay
tribute to their Alma Mater.
So Harvey and I are really
honored to be here today
to host the second series
of the HarvEst Distinguished
Women Leader Lecture Series.
We are very honored that our guest speaker
is Professor Laura Tyson,
who actually was Harvey's
first economics professor,
and she was the one who inspired Harvey
to major in economics,
who in turn inspired me to follow suit.
There's a saying that
women hold up half the sky.
Well, being a full-time mom,
and being a full-time owner
of my own public relations company,
I must say that most of
the time I have to hold up
more than half of a company,
and more than half of the family.
And you know, men are normally considered
as the bread winners of the family,
while women are the pillars of the family,
having to take care of
so many household chores,
kid's education, financial
planning, logistics management,
signing checks, and entertaining guests.
So how do we do it all, right?
It really takes someone with good
time management and multitasking skills.
And I will say, women are
actually quite fortunate
to be born with the talent of
good time management and prioritization,
especially for super achievers
like Professor Tyson,
who also writes books,
who also does research,
who also gives speeches, like today,
and who also advises the
President of the United States.
She indeed is a role model.
Speaking of role model,
over the years that I've been involved
with a lot of women related
business organizations,
and charity organizations,
I've been telling all my 25
mentees that it's very important to find
a good role model or a mentor for life.
Someone who can share with you
their experiences and their insights.
Someone who can inspire
women to empower themselves.
And I think it's very
important that these days,
we as women, have to empower ourselves,
and then have to nurture
our leadership skills
to give back to the community.
And this is indeed the inspiration
behind our endowment of
HarvEst Distinguished
Women Leader Lecture Series,
and as Dean Doyle mentioned earlier,
the series was launched
back in October of 2013,
and we were very honored to
have Mrs. Harriet Fulbright
as our inaugural speaker,
who delivered an enlightening speech
on international education.
And I think you know through
prominent speakers sharing,
we hope that this lecture
series will be able to elevate
the status of women from a socioeconomic,
professional, and personal aspect,
just to let women live up to
my favorite four Ps framework,
which is P for passion.
I think it's very important for someone,
for yourself to find your passion.
To really find what you love doing,
and then to live your
dreams to the fullest.
The second P is for positivity.
This word I use a lot to
teach my kids, Kisha and Tika.
I say, always think positive.
Don't think negative.
Always think of a glass being
half full and not half empty.
Because positivity breeds happiness,
it breeds self-confidence,
it breeds success.
And the third P is for perseverance.
Don't let anything come in
the way to achieve your goal.
It's all about will power,
all about discipline.
And I always, you know
my favorite case study
is to share my own
experience in overcoming
three miscarriages within four years.
But I told myself, at
least I'm conceivable.
I know one day I'm gonna be a mother.
So now I have two beautiful daughters.
And the fourth P is for philanthropy.
Philanthropy meaning giving
back to the community,
giving back to your Alma Mater,
because there are so many unfortunate
and underprivileged people out there
who need our help.
So Harvey and I are really excited today
that we're going to learn
about the fifth P, politics.
(light laughter)
How politics, or policy making,
will empower women in the
workplace, and in the family,
and in turn add value to the economy.
Let us welcome Professor Laura Tyson.
(applause)
Our honorable guest speaker
who will be speaking
on Women's Work in the World Economy
from a Political and Personal Perspective.
(applause)
Thank you.
(whispering)
- Thank you, Esther, you and Harvey
are truly inspirational in your vision for
endowing this lecture series.
Without further ado,
it's my great pleasure
to introduce my colleague,
Professor Laura Tyson.
You have biographical
notes, and Laura said,
"Please don't spend too
long introducing me."
She says, "Basically, I've
been here a very long time."
(laughs)
Professor Tyson joined the
Berkeley faculty in 1977.
She's been on the faculty,
at the Haas School of Business since 1990,
and she was the dean
of the School of Business from 1998-2001.
In addition, as Esther mentioned,
she has advised Presidents
of the United States.
She's the former chair
of the US President's
Council of Economic Advisor,
and former director of the
National Economic Council
under the Clinton administration.
She was the first woman to
hold both of these roles.
And more recently, she served
on President Barack Obama's
Economic Recovery Advisory Board,
so we can thank Laura for
the improving global economy.
(light laughter)
Without further ado, I'm
gonna welcome to the stage,
my colleague, and ask you to do similarly.
(applause)
- I appreciate that.
Well good afternoon everyone.
It's really, it's a honor to be here.
The University of
California Berkeley has been
a major part of my life
for a very long time.
It's actually very inspiring
to actually meet students
who I once taught many years ago.
I was asked when I was in
Washington the first time,
with President Clinton, I had a knack
for making economics fairly simple.
So people would say to me constantly,
"Where did you get the training
"to make economics fairly simple?"
And I said, well, a lecture hall
of 800 freshmen and
sophomores who you had to
keep awake, and keep engaged.
And that was my best training.
So the university has been
extremely important to me,
and I'm very, very thankful to welcome
Esther and Harvey back,
and to realize that I'm connected to them
in that very personally important way.
I'm gonna talk about Women's Work
in the World Economy tonight.
I will focus on the policy aspects,
but also focus on the economic argument.
And I want to start this by saying that
I myself have not spent most of my life
studying women in the global economy.
I got to this issue personally,
and I got fascinated by
it, maybe I developed
a little passion for
it, relatively recently.
The first thing I had passion for
as a student was economics.
And when I studied economics,
I went to Smith College,
and I did not realize,
because I was at an all women's school,
that economics was a male discipline.
So I liked economics.
Most of my professors were actually,
at that point, male professors,
but I thought the
discipline was fantastic.
And I tend therefore to think about
problems that interest
me are economic problems.
I went to MIT, and at MIT I studied
International Economic Development,
in comparative political economy,
how do societies organize themselves
to be competitive, to be prosperous,
to promote rapid growth
in output per person,
to have great productivity,
what do societies do?
So one of the things that
I discovered increasingly
was that, how societies treat women,
their gender, what I'm gonna
call all my gender parity,
the extent to which men and
women are treated equally
in a variety of areas.
That gender parity actually
does have an effect
on an economy's economic performance.
And it's an effect which
actually in the past 20 years
has really been demonstrated
in study after study.
So whereas we might've
thought that before,
we might've just had an
intuition that was true,
we have a very dramatic
amount of evidence now
coming from economists,
coming from psychologists,
coming from political scientists,
coming from countries all over the world,
that countries that have
greater degrees of gender parity
also have a superior economic performance
in a variety of ways.
So I'm gonna talk about that tonight.
I got first interested in this question
because I was, as I said,
I was always interested in economics,
always interested in how societies perform
comparatively, competitively.
But I was the dean of two
business schools also.
The business school here,
right across the street.
A great business school, fantastic,
London Business School also
a wonderful business school.
One if more international
in makeup than the other,
but they're actually at
the top of their game.
And what I discovered,
and I should've known this
but I discovered it,
was that business schools
were one of the few
higher education areas
where women were not yet
at the 50% or parity level
in terms of enrollment.
Women weren't going to business school
to the same extent as men were.
If they went to business school,
they were not staying in business school.
If they graduated from business school,
they were not staying in business.
So this was like, I noticed this.
And I tried to begin to understand,
since I was a female dean
of two business schools,
what business schools might
do to encourage more women.
In the process of thinking about that,
there were others around
the world thinking about
how to, they were looking at
this business case for women,
the economic case for women,
the economic case for gender parity,
I was approached by something called
the World Economic Forum.
So the World Economic
Forum is a non-profit,
it's very influential,
it grew out of actually
an academic institution in
Switzerland 45 years ago.
It has become very
influential around the world.
It brings together great
leaders from around the world,
both business and political leaders,
to talk about pressing economic issues,
and to think about what are the factors
that lead to an economy's success.
So the World Economic Forum approached me
while I was thinking about
why aren't there more
women in business schools,
and said, "We want to put
together a rigorous analysis of
"how countries are doing on gender parity
"in a number of dimensions.
"And then we want to see
how a country's performance
"on gender parity affects
its economic performance."
That was their mission.
And they asked if I would
be interested in doing this,
and I said, absolutely.
Because I had been thinking about it.
So we got some very
good help at the Forum.
We got a couple of really
good data economists.
I'm more of an economist who sort of does
case studies, and country studies,
so we've got some very good,
rigorous data economists.
And we put together a report which has
come to be called the
Global Gender Gap Report.
Now before I start with the numbers,
I wanna tell just a personal anecdote
about my first engagement
with the World Economic Forum,
'cause it predated when they
came to me in 2003 and '04
and said, "Will you work on this issue?".
I had gone to the World Economic Forum
as a member of the US government
working for Bill Clinton,
and my spouse had come along.
And this was the mid 1990s.
So at that point there were very few men
who were spouses at the
World Economic Forum.
(light audience laughter)
There were a whole bunch of women
who were spouses at the
World Economic Forum,
and very few men.
So we arrived, my husband and I,
and he was offered a flowered bag,
and I was offered a black briefcase.
(audience laughter)
He was offered a sleigh ride through town,
and I was offered a panel to discuss
global economic activity.
Back in the mid 1990s,
spouses were not invited to go to
the major sessions of
the World Economic Forum.
By the way, there's at least one person
in the audience who knows
my husband pretty well,
and she can guess, he was not pleased.
(audience laughter)
In fact, he has refused ever to go back
to the World Economic Forum with me,
even though I tell him on a regular basis,
look, no sleigh rides, no flowered bags,
you can go to whatever event you want to,
it's all right, dear.
No, no, he's not coming.
So this is just an anecdote
about changing style,
because now the World Economic Forum,
although in itself has
not reached gender parity,
absolutely not, so 20% of
its participants are women,
but what I will say is
you have some of the
major women leaders
around the world there.
You have major female CEOs there,
you have whole panels talking about
what companies can do to
promote greater gender parity,
what countries can do to
promote greater gender parity.
So its gone from a non-issue
to an absolutely central
issue of the Forum.
And that's because, what
I'm gonna show you now
are some of the results,
what the evidence shows very clearly
is that countries that
develop greater gender parity
over time in a variety of measures,
actually do end up having
superior economic performance,
and we can talk about why.
So let me just tell you
a little bit about this,
what the gender gap is trying to measure.
Now I'm gonna say you can go to the
World Economic Forum website.
The reports there, it's
become the second most
important report of the
World Economic Forum
all around the world,
so people do at least look at it.
It is a very good report,
but it's pretty tedious reading.
You have to go in and
sort of each country,
you look at a whole bunch of measures.
So I'm gonna try to summarize for you
what the results are.
So we tried to measure gender parity
on a variety of dimensions that we thought
were relevant to economic performance.
Obviously education is relevant
to economic performance.
So a country that, if you think about
the workforce as being half female,
you wanna educate the workforce
literate to illiteracy,
primary, secondary, tertiary,
all the way through,
you want to basically
achieve gender parity
in educational opportunity,
and educational attainment.
So that was an obvious one.
Health and survival, obvious.
A country's performance
on the health and survival
of men and women, and
whether there are any
gender issues there is important.
Economic participation and opportunity.
So this is really, we look
at lots of things here.
We look at what economists call
labor force participation rates,
to what extent is the female population
of working age working,
labor force participation.
But we don't just measure that,
we measure pay gaps, gender gaps,
female, male differences in earnings.
And we measure opportunity gaps,
which we kind of look at
through attainment levels,
and you'll see some of that later.
And then political empowerment,
because policies about the economy,
policies about education,
policies about health
are going to be affected
by the gender parity,
or lack thereof, in
political representation.
So these are the areas.
We have 142 countries.
We have 14 variables, we rate them.
We now have nine years of data.
So you can sort of compare
countries over time
in terms of are they improving,
are they improving on one dimension
but declining on another.
So this is what we're attempting to study.
And we believe that four of these,
these four areas are the major ones
for understanding a society's
approach to gender parity,
and we believe it's very important
for economic performance.
So that's the first thing.
Okay, this is a little
graphic which kind of says
how the world is doing.
So each country gets measured,
but we also do a weighted
average of all countries
to sort of say how's the
world on average doing
in gender parity in education,
gender parity in health,
in economic opportunity,
and political empowerment.
And we use weighting measures.
And what you can see right
here is that actually
the world today has made a
tremendous amount of progress
in eliminating gender disparities
in health, and in education.
It has eliminated, not eliminated,
it's reduced disparities in
economic participation and opportunity,
but there's a lot left to do.
So you might read that as
the world has eliminated 60% of the gap.
And then in political empowerment,
we have a long way to go.
Around the world,
there's a long way to go.
Now I wanna say something about,
I wanna warn you about these numbers
before I show some countries.
Just because a country
is doing pretty well
in terms of parity, doesn't mean that
the level of education
or health is that high.
So we have a whole bunch of countries.
Some are very developed.
And they have a high
degree of gender parity.
That means they're getting
high levels of education,
high levels of health,
and not much gender
difference in those areas.
You have some very poor countries
who actually are doing
pretty well in gender parity,
but they're poor, they're poor.
So their degree of tertiary education
for both men and women might be low,
or their degree of health
outcomes might be low
for both men and women.
So I just wanna make sure
that one understands that
to have a country score,
a country score of one on something
means complete gender parity.
Okay?
Very few countries get
that on almost anything,
so now we will go to the next slide.
Who's in the lead?
This is a graph which just shows averages,
so those little lines are averages.
Not to be, you would not
be surprised that we,
when you look at these
countries, 142 countries,
there's gonna be a regional effect.
So the highest average
gender parity measures
are in North America, the US and Canada,
however if you go down to
Europe and Central Asia,
Europe has actually, those ones
way on the the right there,
they are basically the
best performers in the lot,
and I'm gonna talk about them in a minute.
There is a group of
European countries who,
on all dimensions,
outperform everybody else.
And some of you can probably
guess which ones those are.
They're on the right.
If you go down to the Middle
East and North Africa,
you'll see the average is the lowest,
and you have some very
extreme outliers there.
This shows, and I'll get to
a table, or a slide later,
when you think about reasons
for gender disparities,
clearly one of them is
going to be cultural.
And I think you see
both a development level
and a cultural level showing up
in some of these regional differences.
Let me just, since countries
like to see where they are,
one of the fascinating things about
if you ever create an index of everything,
excuse me, create an index
of anything by country,
countries start to compete on it.
So actually, this report
has become widely read.
In part because country leaders,
business leaders in a
country, NGOs in a country,
educational institutions, look
at how the country's doing,
and then they try to figure out
what can they do to get better.
So this has the top 20 over here.
You'll see the United States is number 20.
And then it has some of the
other countries over there
going to the bottom,
Yemen 142, Pakistan 141,
and Saudi Arabia 130.
And by the way, Saudi Arabia
has improved its gender gap,
it's reduced its gender gap
in the last couple of years.
It's moving in the right direction,
but it's still as a ranking phenomenon,
one of the least performing countries.
So let's talk a little bit
about who's in the lead.
So you'll see those top
five countries there,
they're the Nordic countries.
For some of you in this room,
that would not be a surprise,
you would predict that.
That actually suggests a combination
of culture and policy
are very important here,
the policy is reflecting the culture.
And so when you have things
like compulsory paternity leave,
not just maternity leave,
but paternity leave,
so you don't have any
scapegoating of men and women,
both parents have to take leave
to take care of the children.
When you have highly subsidized childcare
that lasts a very long time,
when you have support
for part-time workers
at full-time salaries
so that people have time
to take care of their children,
for both men and women.
Those are reflections of
a set of social norms,
which actually end up in policy
that actually does have an
effect on gender parity.
If you go to the US for a minute,
the US, not a bad performer.
This number says we've eliminated
75% of our aggregate gender gap.
Where the US is weakest is politics.
We do not do well here.
We're like, the way we measure politics,
we've only eliminated 20% of the gap.
I think we're number 60
out of 142 countries.
We have a lot of room to go
in politics in the United States.
We measure politics here
in parliamentary seats,
ministerial positions, and head of state.
You might say, now this
is just for those of you
who think about the challenges
of doing something like this with data.
An ideal thing would be to
include mayors, or city council.
The problem is, you can't
get numbers like that
for the 142 countries.
You can't get it from
many countries at all,
so if you're trying to
do this comparatively,
you have to chose data, statistics,
measures that are common across countries.
And that's how we end up with ministers,
parliamentarians and heads of state.
If we managed to have a head of state
as a woman in the next few years,
this would fundamentally
change our position.
But that's, I'm not
saying anything political.
That's a purely statistical
observation, all right.
(audience laughter)
Purely statistical.
Dynamics of the gender gaps.
So we've done this for
nine years, any progress?
Not a whole lot.
There's stuff going on in pol--
First of all, this shows
very clearly, again,
that the biggest gaps around
the world are in politics.
The most reduced gaps are
in education and health,
and the economic participation
and opportunities
are kind of in the middle there.
We have made some progress
around the world in political empowerment.
The progress is pretty slow.
You can barely see, you
can see a little progress
in the economic participation
and opportunity line.
The last time the report came out,
my colleagues at the World Economic Forum
used the rate of progress
in economic participation and opportunity,
and concluded if the world continues
at the progress of the last nine years,
it'll take 81 years to
close the gender gap
in economic participation and opportunity.
So I think the world's
gonna be better than that.
I don't think it's gonna take 81 years,
but that's what we found out.
So.
Now next.
Okay.
So now, this is what
the World Economic Forum
when they started to do this,
this is a question they were
interested in answering.
Remember, the World Economic Forum
made its reputation by ranking countries
on their competitiveness
in the global economy.
It's something called the
Global Competitiveness Index.
And that's how they made their reputation.
When I was back there with
my husband and flowered bags,
that's the index they had.
And they had a whole host
of things they measured
that they thought might be correlated
with competitiveness,
national competitiveness.
Things like the rule of law, open trading,
regulation, education.
Gender, not there.
Not there.
Remember, it was the mid
1990s, gender wasn't there.
So the challenge for us was to say
would gender parity show up
as something that we
think it's related to,
global competitiveness,
but does it show up?
So this suggests that yes, there
is a positive relationship,
it's statistically significant,
between how a country performs on its
global gender gap index, and
its global competitiveness.
So moving towards gender parity
is associated with a
more competitive outcome.
And so the whole reason
for doing the study
in the first place,
once we had the numbers
we could say okay, that seems to be
a relationship that makes sense.
And then there's another one you can do,
but it's a little bit the same thing.
Global competitiveness is linked to
global GDP per capita, and GDP per capita
is the economist's favorite
measure of prosperity,
so you measure a country's
prosperity by GDP per capita.
And this says, yes, there
is a relationship between
the global gender gap
index and GDP per capita.
So those were things that we
had anticipated finding out,
and we did find them.
So.
Now I'm gonna,
maybe I shouldn't put this one up yet.
There's a lot more that I now wanna say,
moving from the World
Economic Forum itself
to actually other work that's been done
during this whole period, on women,
gender parity, and economic performance.
So the World Economic Forum is one study,
one set of measures that
looks at this relationship.
I mentioned at the beginning,
there's been a lot of
work going on on this,
the International Monetary
Fund is working on it,
the World Bank is working on it,
development economists have worked on it.
And basically what they are working on,
is how does a greater gender parity
affect economic performance, and why?
How does it affect it, and why?
Now to some extent, this is intuitive,
it's absolutely intuitive.
If half of the global
labor force was women,
and if women are becoming
as educated as men,
and we saw that in
terms of the gender gaps
in education really
disappearing around the world,
then clearly, if you
believe that human talent
has an effect on economic performance,
then what you want to do is say that
greater gender parity
and economic opportunity
and participation will mean
greater mobilization of talent,
and that will lead to
superior economic performance.
It's a very simple intuitive relationship.
And I think that's really what
a lot of the research is now focused on.
Now if you think about it that way,
how does one look at measurements
of mobilizing gender talent.
One simple way is what I mentioned before,
labor force participation rates.
The International Monetary Fund
is headed by a very outstanding
woman, Christine Lagarde,
and when she goes around the
world talking to countries
and giving them advice
about how to promote
their future economic prosperity,
this is one of the
statistics she focuses on.
Labor force participation rate for women,
and if you can get that
labor force participation
rate for women up to
closer to that for men,
there will be faster economic growth.
So the OECD, for example,
has estimated that if
there was gender parity
in labor force participation rates between
men and women in the developed economies,
that would lead to an
increase by about 12%
of GDP per capita over a 20 year basis.
That's a big number.
You know, people sit
around all around the world
trying to figure out what to do
to promote economic growth,
that number is a big number.
So if you can figure out a way
to mobilize women into the workforce,
that is gonna be a big movement towards
superior economic performance.
But it's not just mobilizing
women in the workforce.
The other things you
have to worry about are
around the world, in the US,
in every country to some extent,
even in the Nordic countries,
women tend to be over represented
in relatively low productivity,
part-time, low pay, with
low advancement opportunity
sectors of the economy.
They're over represented there,
and they're under represented in high pay,
high productivity, high
opportunity sectors.
So if you actually are interested
in mobilizing female talent,
it's not just getting them to participate
in the workforce as much as men,
but to have them have the opportunities
in these high productivity,
high performance,
high pay, high opportunity careers.
So looking at that suggests one looks at
not just the labor force
participation rates,
but the wage gaps, or the wage rates,
or the productivity differences.
And what you see there is just
like all around the world,
the labor force
participation rates of women
tend to be lower than men.
There is a persistent wage gap.
Now the wage gap varies by country.
It varies by sector.
But you would still say
that it's persistent,
it's measurable, and it's significant.
It's not a trivial number.
And part of that gap of course,
is that women are caught more
in these low productivity, low pay jobs.
But even if you hold constant sector,
even if you hold constant jobs,
then you still see the wage gap.
So for example, in the US, female earnings
remain lower than men's
for similar skill levels
in nearly all occupations.
That's in the US.
Including occupations that
are predominantly held by men,
and occupations that are
predominantly held by women.
Even in occupations
predominantly held by women,
there is a wage gap.
And that's for women of
same educational levels.
So that's important.
Another thing that's important,
certainly relevant to
this audience I would say,
is the wage gap tends to start small
for young women entering the labor force,
certainly in developed countries.
That would be true in the US.
Small wage gap at the beginning
gets bigger over time.
Increases with child birth.
But here's a surprise,
is larger among top earners
and those with high levels
of educational attainment.
It gets larger.
And that, of course, is partly because
of what has been commonly
called opting out,
or motherhood, or taking care
of family responsibilities.
You know there was
just, and I urge you all
to take a look at it,
it's really remarkable.
My son just got married three weeks ago.
Harvard Business School does a big survey
of male and female graduates
over the past 40 years.
So they have some graduates
who are baby boomers like myself,
they have some millennials,
who are just 30 years old.
They asked the men and the women
what they expected in terms of
did they think their
career would be equally
as important as their
partners, or less important,
and did they think
childcare responsibilities
would be equally shared,
or unequally shared.
Women thought they were equally important,
and responsibilities
would be equally shared.
Men did not.
(audient laughter)
These are expectations of Harvard
Business School graduates.
Right, so this is now, this is today.
This is right now.
So you think about how the pressures on,
when you see these numbers,
okay, the wage gap starts out not there,
and then develops over time,
and it develops over time with children,
and people opting out, and
all the responsibilities
that Esther said you have to juggle,
you still have to juggle.
And societies that have made it easier,
that's the Nordic countries,
tend to have over time,
better performance here
because they're taking some of
these family balancing issues
and they are working to make them easier.
So it's just an important point
about the opting out
pressures of family on women,
and the fact that the OECD says
their estimate is the wage penalty,
terrible thing to say, per child,
7% of your earnings.
Okay.
This is among developed countries.
So this is some of the issues.
Now, I wanna go from that however,
to make two important observations.
Number one, the opting out
phenomenon is real, and costly,
but it does not say, in any way,
that women are less ambitious than men.
So again, in developed countries
there are lots of surveys,
including the Harvard survey
that I just talked about,
aspirationally speaking,
women want the same thing.
They want the same thing on average.
It's just harder for them to achieve.
So this is not about
aspiration and ambition,
this is about how complicated
it is to achieve that.
And the next thing is to say that
it's hard to achieve it not just because
many women are balancing work life,
it's hard to achieve it
because our workplaces
aren't really organized very well
to take, to promote gender parity.
And so for that I'll use
this pipeline number.
Okay, so this comes from McKinsey,
and there are two
different sort of surveys
that lead to the same result here.
One is a survey of pipeline of women
in Fortune 500 companies,
another one is a set of surveys they did
with their own participants.
You can see here that in the US,
and this can be true in the
developed countries as well,
most of the developed countries as well,
women are at entry
level professions doing,
companies are coming
around to business schools
around the world, and
they are absolutely intent
on recruiting at parity.
50%, 50%.
In this survey, actually the women were
outperforming men a little bit.
But then you can see the fall off.
The fall off to middle management,
then the fall off to senior management,
then the fall off to executive committee,
then the fall off to top position.
So by the time you get
to the top position,
I think the current number
for the US Fortune 500
is 5%, but we're not talking
about a major difference.
So now we have a variety,
we have a large number of
experts around the world
who are doing a variety of techniques
to figure out why this happens.
Why does this happen?
Some of this is opting out,
but it's not all opting
out, it's absolutely not.
There is a lot of evidence that women
are not giving line opportunities
to the same extent as men are.
That they don't go in and negotiate
for a line opportunity to the
same extent that a man does,
that the performance
indicators that are used
in the workplace are not picking up
women's performance as well as men.
Again, I'll just point
out that there have been
some really interesting
articles you can take a look at,
a series that Sheryl Sandberg
is doing with Adam Grant,
who's a very well known
organizational behavior economist,
and they're in the New York Times,
and they're doing a series,
and one of the things you
can see are things like
on average evaluations of
women in the workplaces
tend to be more critical.
There was a killer article
just a couple weeks ago
in something called the
Upshot in the New York Times
where they actually, I don't
know if you saw this, Fiona,
but they actually looked at rankings
of male and female professors
by students around the country,
and both male and female students
were much tougher on the women.
Much tougher on the women
in terms of using words
that were much more
sort of, the bossy word,
the aggressive word, the insensitive word.
Not the leadership word,
not the kind of talent word,
not the, so there are all
kinds of evaluation issues
that I think are real.
And that shows up in the pipeline as well.
Another pipeline measure
for you is Credits Suisse
just did a really interesting study,
and they said, "We have another problem."
Women get in the pipeline,
but they get in the pipeline in terms of
shared services, things
where team spirit matters.
Things with a common service
like human resources,
or investor relations.
They get much less into the CFO,
and then operations, no, that's not where
they get the promotion opportunities,
and then of course, the operations
tend to lead oftentimes to CEO positions,
so they're not in that.
So I think we have a
whole lot of work to do
in developed countries, in companies,
and in policy, to think
about what we can do
to improve the flow
through in the pipeline.
Because after all, if
women are getting educated
to this very high level,
and we're losing them in the pipeline,
and some of that can be improved by better
workplace training, better
workplace evaluation of talent,
then we should do that.
That's better for the company,
it's better for the individual,
it's better for the country.
So that's something
that I think has become
a big focus of research now in many,
many business schools, including at Haas.
So companies.
There's growing evidence that
the business case for promoting women
is actually very strong.
So what we have is a
more diverse leadership
of a company means the
company better reflects
the profiles of employees and customers.
It has, there's a lot of
evidence that more diverse teams
lead to better decisions,
so diversity in teams,
both gender diversity
and other kinds of diversity
leads to better decisions.
Companies that are ranked on indicators
of organizational health, like
how well do people get along,
open communications, trust,
more where there's greater diversity,
or greater parity in leadership,
those companies get ranked
as having higher organizational health.
And then what Credit Suisse has reported,
and others have found the same thing,
is companies that have more gender parity
in their pipeline all
the way through the top,
tend to have better financial performance.
So let me summarize
where we are right now.
There's a very strong
country level economic case
that moving towards greater gender parity,
achieving gender equality
in health, education,
economic engagement and
political empowerment
have beneficial effects on
national economic performance.
There is a very strong literature,
and it's become very compelling to read,
that that is also true at
the level of companies.
And the biggest global
companies in the world now
recognize this and are
trying to figure out
how to mobilize more female talent.
So the country level data suggests
it's gonna take 81 years to get to parity.
The company level data
says, for the Fortune 500
we're only 5% of leadership,
we got a lot of space we need to fill up,
what's going on, what are the barriers?
What can we work on?
From a policy point of view,
or from a company point of view,
or from a university point of view,
what can we work on to
get this moving faster
to greater gender parity?
Because we'll all be better off.
So this is just a table you can take
to think about if you're
interested in this,
and I tried to put together some issues
that were both at the
level of the individual.
Things we can do at the
level of the individual,
things we need to address
at the level of culture,
things that companies
or universities can do
at the level of the workplace,
and what policy makers can do to try to
get us to make progress faster.
We still need to make progress,
there are benefits to progress,
we're not going fast enough, okay.
So I'm not gonna go through all these
'cause then we'd be here for five hours.
I'm just gonna pick out
a couple of the ones
that I think are really interesting here.
Educational choices.
So this is the level of the student
and what they choose to study.
So this is an educational institution.
Walter Isaacson wrote that
wonderful book about innovation.
He has written a lot about the
role of women in computers.
In 1985, 37% of computer science
undergraduate degrees
were earned by women.
In 2010, only 18% of
computer science degrees
were earned by women,
and less that 1% of
female college freshmen
say they plan to major
in computer science.
Less than 1%.
Now, the majority, the top
10 most remunerative careers
are associated with
certain college majors.
One of those is computer science, okay.
If you sort of look at the
other nine of the top 10,
they're in STEM,
they're science, technology,
engineering, and math.
In all 10 of those highly
remunerative majors,
meaning majors that lead to
highly remunerative positions,
the majority of majors are men.
Women are the majority of majors
in the 10 least remunerative majors.
10 least ones.
So this is partly a choice,
and I think what people
are working very hard on
is where does this choice come from.
Does this have to do with
the fact that for me,
economics was not a male discipline,
I was fine with economics,
I didn't have to worry about
all of the stereotyping,
or cultural biases against
doing a male major 'cause
I was in a female school,
there were no males.
So there's a whole set of things going on,
really starting at preschool,
5th grade, 8th grade,
college, trying to figure
out how to make it,
how to deal with this choice
when we think that the choice may not be
maybe structured by some of the
cultural norms like stereotyping.
So I would just leave that as one.
Individuals need to change
their choices partly,
if we're going to make progress on this.
Cultural, look, I've already
talked about work life
balance, priorities, and
I think I will leave that.
The spousal role in
support comes directly from
the Harvard Business School
study I just mentioned.
By the way, I have not raised with my son
and daughter-in-law whether
they ever had that discussion,
and what their expectations are,
so I'm staying out of this.
Workplace.
I wanna focus on this because companies
are focusing on mentorship and training.
They feel that, and I think
Esther mentioned this,
how important mentors are,
and if you, part of that
pipeline deterioration
is that women don't
have access to mentors,
because there are not that
many women ahead of them
who can be the mentor or the model.
So they have to rely upon male mentors,
and maybe male mentors are
not as engaged with them,
or maybe they feel there's some distance.
So mentorship and training
is very important.
Awareness and accountability.
I wanna talk about that
because it came so much
to the forefront last fall.
So last fall the relatively
new CEO of Microsoft
was at an event that was celebratory
of women in computer science.
And he was asked a question
about whether women
should ask for raises.
He said he thought women
shouldn't ask for raises
because that was bad karma.
(audience laughter)
He actually said that if
women didn't ask for raises,
their talent would be recognized
and they would get a raise.
Okay.
That's a very meritocratic answer.
But it turns out it flies in the face of
a lot of evidence we have.
We have a lot of evidence,
and the evidence suggests two things.
Number one.
Women on average, this
is not true of all women,
so all of these are averages,
do not like to negotiate.
Women describe negotiation
as like going to the dentist.
Men describe negotiation as
like going to a ballgame.
They like it.
So the evidence suggests
that equally competent
men and women will, the
women are much less likely
to ask for a raise, much less likely.
Because they don't feel good about that.
Now if you are a CEO, you're a company
and you wanna promote female talent,
you have to know that.
You have to know that,
and you have to design
your human resources policies
to deal with that reality.
That is the reality.
Women are less confident than men,
and they are less, on average,
and they are less comfortable
with negotiating for wages.
So you have to know that
to get awareness and accountability.
Absolutely need to know that.
So there's a whole list of
research that deals with that.
And then structure and policy.
I've talked about this in terms of
the countries that are really
moving the furthest here.
The focus is on shared parental leave,
childcare assistance, tax policy,
because you don't wanna have a tax policy
which is differentiated in such a way
that it discourages the second
earner of the family to work.
You certainly need to have
workplace equality laws,
I mean you need to have
the basic institutions
that are in place.
And then the last one,
organizations designed
for men in manufacturing.
This gets to workplace flexibility.
This gets to the issue of most jobs today
do not require a physical
presence all the time
on a production line,
and since flexibility turns out
to be of critical importance
to women, particularly at
certain times in their life,
organizing the workplace
around flexibility
is gonna become more and more important.
So now I'm gonna leave you
with my most fun slide,
but I wanna say with this slide
that this reflects the work
ongoing of a group of scholars
around the country who
are trying to look at
relevant differences in gender behavior,
that are relevant to policy makers.
They're thinking about what can we do
to promote gender parity,
or to business leaders who are thinking
what can we do to promote gender parity.
You need to know these
kinds of differences
if you're going to do the right things.
So these are some of the differences.
Men show up in study after
study to be more confident.
In study after study
they turn up to be more,
they like competition more.
They are willing to negotiate more.
Women worry about backlashes,
they worry about stereotypes,
they're a little worried about,
when you see these results
of how the students
evaluated their professors,
you're a little worried about stereotypes.
Okay, you're a little worried about being
the bossy, unfeeling, domineering woman.
Which if you use the same words for men
would be the leader,
insightful, inspiring male.
So these are just a whole
variety of differences,
and I'll leave you, again,
we can talk about any one of these,
but the good news here is that
scholars around the country,
and indeed around the world,
using very sophisticated techniques now,
are actually confirming, to my mind,
some things of gender differences which
anecdotally I heard all my life,
but actually now I can see
that in experimental settings,
or in large survey
settings with a lot of data
and a lot of rigor,
they're being documented.
So now let me conclude here,
because I was asked to make
this a little bit personal,
with some personal
observations about my own life.
I started with the fact that
Berkeley was very important to me.
Academic life is a kind of life
which does allow you to ramp your time up
and ramp your time down.
To opt out a little bit when
your child is really young,
then to opt back in, figure a year later.
So there are certain occupations
which are naturally more
flexible than others,
and university professor, for me,
I mean I always wanted to
be a university professor,
not because of that,
but it turned out that
that was really good, that
was really a big plus.
But I do wanna say that
in thinking about my own life,
first of all, my son
asked me a few years ago,
he said, "Mom, the women I'm dating
"want you to write a book because
"they wanna know how you did it."
And he said, "And I don't
know how you did it.
"I was your son, but I have no idea."
I didn't write the book,
maybe I should've at that point.
But I do think that, besides
having a flexible job,
which would be part of my answer,
being an academic at a
prestigious university
which was flexible with me
was a very important
part of what I could do.
So a workplace designed with flexibility
in mind is gonna be great.
But frankly, I also had a
largely stay at home spouse.
So if you read Sheryl
Sandberg's book Lean In,
she has two lessons in her book.
One is lean in, negotiate,
say what you're willing
to do to take that job,
don't let yourself be overlooked,
all those things about
negotiating, competition,
those things are part of leaning in.
She also says marry the right person.
(audience laughter)
Now I wanna say, I do think,
I don't know how you manage
to figure this all out,
is there like some big
job interview that you do,
anyway, spouses really do matter
because of all the things
we talked about earlier.
Partnerships matter.
I think Esther and Harvey's
partnership really matters.
You can see this, one of the things
that's really interesting is
if you look at Catalyst,
Catalyst is a very good
source of information
on gender differences in businesses.
So 75% of men holding
top business positions
in the United States have spouses
or partners who are not employed.
75%.
Okay, not employed.
75% of women holding similar positions
have spouses or partners
who are employed full-time.
Balance, balance, balance.
I had a spouse who was working from home,
and so that made my life
considerably easier.
And I, in thinking about what lessons
I would have for people,
the lessons are flexible
career, flexible spouse,
spouse who works at home.
They're not generally applicable, I'd say.
However, even in that setting,
the job I had that was most inflexible
was working for Bill Clinton.
Any working for any president,
there's no flexibility in that.
No flexibility.
So that job was a job that I had,
that my husband had, that my son had.
It was our job.
It was a family job.
At the end of four years,
the two other people who
had the job besides me,
said, "We're done with this job.
"We're going back to Berkeley.
"You're welcome to come with us."
Now, I decided to come with them.
I could've stayed.
I actually had the opportunity
to get a cabinet level position,
and I told the president I was going.
But this is about the
nature of jobs, by the way,
because I wasn't the
only person who did that.
Bob Reich, who's a professor at Cal,
and a good friend of mine,
and my husband happens to be
out to dinner with him tonight,
Bob Reich and his family went through
exactly the same discussion
at exactly the same time.
And Bob and I both left government.
So there are certain careers,
and certain inflexibilities
where you have to
essentially say, this is a family,
and families have to balance
over the lifetime of a family
how you deal with spousal
issues of careers.
Last night, Ruth Bader
Ginsburg was being interviewed,
and she said, "You know,
when I was younger,
"my husband wanted to make
it in this New York law firm
"in five years, in record time."
She said, "I did everything
so he could do that."
And she said, "Since then,
"he's been doing everything for me."
(laughter)
That was the balance
they did in their life.
So there are very important
personal parts of this
that you can't, a workplace
can design a flexible job.
But some jobs are not gonna be flexible,
and therefore the flexibility's
gonna have to come
in the family and the
expectations of the family.
So I think that leaning
in is important for women.
Leaning in is important for their spouses.
Leaning in is also
important for companies,
that is, companies have to say,
"What can I do to make my workplace
"a more flexible, gender
parity supporting workplace?"
Companies have to lean in.
And of course, governments
have to lean in.
And this is where I hope,
the US is not at all a leader here.
Absolutely not a leader here
compared to other developed countries.
I mean, just think about it this way.
In France you get, I think,
a month and a half off
from work before your child is born,
two and a half months after,
and then you get full pay
for working 80% of the time.
That's how they've handled it.
Different societies handle it,
but they have very
supportive family policies,
and the US does not.
And as a consequence of that,
one of the things that's happened is
our labor force participation rates
are no longer leading the world,
and our wage gap numbers are
no longer leading the world.
That is, we're not showing,
some people say that what's happened
is we achieved a lot of increasing
gender parity for a while,
and then we kinda hit a wall,
we hit a wall around 2000,
and since that time labor
force participation rates
for women in the US have been coming down,
and the wage gap has stabilized.
So women were making progress
at closing the wage gap,
but then it just stopped.
So we need to think about,
from a policy point of view,
if we're committed to
greater gender parity,
what to do in the United States.
So why don't I leave it
policy, family, companies.
There are great benefits to be had
from promoting gender parity.
There's lots to be done.
When we do it, we have to understand
that there are these
underlying differences
in how people behave,
and we have to shape our
institutions accordingly.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you very much for a talk that was
not only inspiring, but also wise.
- Thank you.
- I'd love to dominate the questions,
but I know there are lots
of people in the audience
who also have questions.
Because we're taping this,
one of the wonderful things we do
is record these lectures and post them
so that people can review
them for posterity.
I'd ask anybody who was questions
to come up to the mic here
so that their questions can be heard.
So, yes please start.
- Thank you.
Laura, your points hit
home on so many levels.
I'm a headhunter, I do executive search
for software start-up
companies in Silicon Valley.
I have for years been saying
exactly what you said up there,
that women won't negotiate,
that women won't take
chances, they're risk averse.
They don't wanna be entrepreneurs,
they'd rather work for somebody
else, they don't want that.
They won't go out on a limb,
they don't have the confidence.
So what can I do when female after female,
and it takes a long time to find
a really qualified female executive,
turns me down for an offer because
they don't wanna trade
off maybe a little bit
of cash compensation for
equity in the company,
or because they feel that they've reached
a point of prominence in a large company
and think to themselves, "If I leave,
"I won't feel that status
that I've attained."
- So look, I don't think,
I think to some extent,
particularly on these kinds of things,
I think the most you can do
is point out to individuals,
whether they're male or female,
that, though they're making a choice,
they should understand that that choice
may reflect a broader
set of cultural norms
that they've absorbed without even
realizing they've absorbed them.
I mean, you both have to
give people the opportunity
to say I'm a more risk averse person,
but I think by letting people know,
you know women are more risk averse.
If you're a mentor and you're saying
women tend to be more risk averse,
are you sure this is, did you know that?
Do you feel that maybe
you should take this risk?
It's a little bit more talking to them
about the evidence, and making
it a little less personal.
But at the end of the day,
I don't think you can,
if that's their decision,
it is their decision, it
absolutely is their decision.
Then what you can do
for the kind of careers
you're talking about, is actually work on
why women choose the majors they choose.
Or why they, do they not
see role models that,
if there are not enough
role models out there
for them to see, then the
risk to them seems higher,
so they're less likely to do it.
So in a sense you have to say,
choose the riskier major,
choose the riskier career
because you could be a model.
And you can't expect to see
a lot of models out there
because there are not yet.
But I don't know, I tend
in these kinds of things
when I'm talking to young women
just to point out that they exist.
And so I've talked to
women who actually said,
a woman recently was talking about
how she felt she was not being paid
appropriately at a venture capital firm,
and I said well, have you gone in
and talked to them about it?
"Well no, I don't feel
comfortable doing it."
And then I say you actually have to do it.
You have to do it because you're
just confirming the notion
of the unwillingness to
negotiate actually will affect
how you're paid over time.
That's just the way it is.
Those are the norms.
Until the companies themselves say,
"I understand that
there's this difference,
"therefore I'm gonna go
out and actually not,
"I'm gonna evaluate men
and women in such a way
"that negotiating differences
don't affect outcomes."
That would be the
company's solution to that.
For the individual solution to that,
it's gotta be to recognize
that these differences exist,
and that it's worth going in.
Because if you go in, see I
think you can go in and say,
"By the way, I'm here,
and the CEO of Microsoft
"said something and
it's actually not true.
"Women in general are not being recognized
"for their performance,
"and I think I wanna bring
it to your attention."
You could actually bring a
whole bunch of this evidence
into the room with you.
So, but look, I don't have a solution,
because women do, even
though it may be the case
that a lot of the women
you're dealing with
are women who have been affected
by these cultural norms,
and if they could sort
of break out of them
and behave differently,
they have been affected,
so I don't know how to change that.
I don't know how to change that.
- [Woman] Throughout this
whole talk I've been thinking
how grateful I was that you were my mentor
my first year here on the faculty
at UC Berkeley in teaching.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] So thank you.
- Thank you, I was very happy to do it.
- [Woman] We did a study
between, I think, 11 universities
that looked at STEM disciplines,
and their percentage within both academia
and in industry, and partly
there were some people
from the European Union there.
And it was interesting
looking at your statistics
about these are jobs,
these are disciplines
where there's higher income earning,
and so the higher empowerment.
But we did find that in
an interesting reversal
than the pattern you were showing,
that in many of the
Scandinavian countries,
and Switzerland, the percentage of women
actually in engineering
or STEM disciplines
is relatively low, and
Turkey was the highest.
- That's interesting,
that's very interesting.
- [Woman] So did you ever
disaggregate by discipline
in any of those studies?
- So I was using a whole
bunch of different studies
which sort of come to
the kind of conclusions
that I was suggesting to you.
I said at the beginning, these are not,
none of these are my
exact area of expertise.
I do know that number that
I gave you about majors,
that was a US number,
that was a kind of choice
of majors in the US.
I certainly think that
as much as possible,
the important thing to do here
is cross country comparisons.
I mean that's one of the
reasons I recommend highly
this report that Credit
Suisse did recently,
because they looked at the pipelines
of women to top management positions,
and board positions, across
a wide variety of countries,
and you see that narrowing
pipeline every place.
So you actually do have
a lot of countries now,
you can see that parity
at the beginning is largely achieved,
but it really dissipates significantly,
and then the question is what's common
to the companies or the countries
that explains this common phenomenon.
But I'm not, what would
be interesting to me
to think about in the
Scandinavian cases is
do women, because of the
cultural norms there,
the pay differentials
between these careers
may not be nearly as dramatic
as they are in the United States.
So the very big differences in pay
that result from STEM
versus non-STEM in the US
may be much more extreme
than it is in Scandinavia.
After all, we know in Scandinavia
that teachers are paid much better
than they're paid here.
So just as a start you'd expect
the differential not to be that large.
- [Women] I think that's it.
They would talk about,
particularly in Denmark,
the cultural differences
whereas the women from Turkey
and Algeria said it wasn't gendered,
engineering wasn't
considered to be gendered.
- So yes, how do you explain that
computer science became so
gendered in the United States?
I don't understand that myself.
So I don't have, you need to tell us that.
But it's very important.
Look, one of the things
that's absolutely true
is that if you look,
another thing about the
Credit Suisse study.
So they looked at breakdowns by sector,
as well as by country.
And of course, certain
sectors have much less
gender disparity in outcome in
companies than other sectors.
So mining and manufacturing
have the biggest disparities.
Recreation and health are
gonna have smaller disparities.
You still see the disparities,
but they're much smaller.
So part of this is also sectoral.
So there's a lot of, what
I tried to do in the talk
is sort of say that
there are common things,
there are enough common
things across companies
and across countries that there is
a gender issue wherever you look.
It manifests itself differently,
but there are gender issues,
both in politics and in
economic participation.
That's what I would say.
- [Fiona] We'll take one last question.
- Okay, thank you.
Hi, my name is Michael Stager,
I work in Global Economics
with the Schuler Institute.
I really appreciate your speaking tonight.
And my question, I came
actually to hear what you think,
what I think is probably the most
important question on the planet today.
And I wanted your input.
And so, freedom to make
one point of context
before I can make the question.
So Chancellor Merkel
and President Hollande
recently made a trip to Moscow,
and then again to Minsk.
And there was discussion,
there was a presentation
by a former ambassador to
Russia, Jack Matlock, recently,
at the National Press Club,
that we are closer to nuclear war today
than we were even in the
1962 Cuban Missile Crisis.
So the world is in grave danger.
Many Americans, many people in the world
are very unaware of such things,
but clearly the events and steps taken
by Merkel and Hollande
indicates such a situation.
Now the other side of it,
and this is the economic
question, is Greece,
and what Greece indicates.
Because it's a very big question,
and Greece has an option.
Where I'm not sure the
European Union does.
There are nations now known as the BRICS,
Russia, China, India,
Brazil, South Africa,
nations like Egypt or Argentina
which are joining them,
with incredible economic
growth commitments.
Engineering, science, food production.
Just remarkable process.
So I'd like to know, we have an initiative
for the United States to join
in that process, the BRICS,
and I'd like to know if you would
support something like that,
and what you generally think
in this political context
of this economic question,
which does seem to be
a bit of an east, west,
or just a divide of two
systems in the world today.
I don't think the question's
relevant to this talk,
but I have thought a lot.
I mean if you're talking about BRICS,
Brazil, Russia, is that
what you mean by BRICS?
So the truth is, and it is relevant
to this talk in one respect,
there is an inexorable
and significant shift
in the weight of the global economy,
away from the developed
countries towards the BRICS,
towards the emerging market economies.
The two major economies that
drive global growth today
are the US and China.
China is growing, even with
a significant slow down,
twice as fast as the US.
China does, actually, quite a good job,
and it would be interesting to hear
Esther and Harvey talk about
this, on gender issues,
on mobilizing their
talented female workforce,
and on educating their female workforce.
But there clearly is this shift going on
in the world economy,
and different society,
so what I was trying to say by this
is that you can see that across society,
at different levels of development,
even ones that have been committed to
gender parity for a very long time,
and have it deeply embedded
in their cultural norms,
and deeply embedded in their
political institutions,
have a ways to go, and those
would be the Nordic countries.
A very interesting
thing going on right now
is Japan is basically
studying as much as possible
what's going on in the Nordic countries,
and trying to do exactly the same thing.
I mean, it's really quite interesting.
They've adopted the Nordic
countries as their example.
But the emerging market countries,
I mean, so here's, when we listed
all the countries by gender gap,
certain countries came forward
to the World Economic Forum and said,
"We would like to set up a task force
"with business leaders in our society
"to improve our performance on
the gender parity measures."
So what were these countries?
One was Turkey.
One was Korea.
One is India.
And one is Mexico.
So these are countries that
just came forward and said,
"You know, we really
think we can do better.
"We see the case here,
"we see that there's
economic benefit to this.
"We see that we have very talented women
"that we're not mobilizing enough.
"Let us work on this together."
So I think, let's say emerging markets
are becoming more and more important,
and a number of the big ones now
are focused on this issue.
And that's how I will
relate to the question,
because it's hard for
me to draw another link.
Okay.
- [Man] Professor Tyson.
- Yes.
- [Man] As a former student,
last time we met I was
finishing my PhD at UCLA.
I've also worked since
on development issues.
I've actually seen a very clear connection
with your presentation today,
which is really talking
about how social constructs
manifest themselves in economic processes.
Whether it's at the
micro level of the firm,
or just individual decisions.
But what's really interesting is that
as the economy is also
shaping and transforming
the way that industry is formed,
and these countries
are competing to absorb
the highest levels of productivity,
they're also trying to adopt
and reform, and transform,
the social constructs
that define productivity.
- Okay, I think that's very important.
- [Man] So by breaking down
these types of studies,
we're actually able to see
how these social constructs
perpetuate inequality,
perpetuate on productivity,
and so for one perspective I'm going to
be building off of the work
that you've just laid out
in work that I'm doing in
the Middle East in Dubai,
and really looking at how we can use this
as examples to look at other groups
that aren't participating,
specifically people with disabilities.
I myself have a severe disability,
but have benefited from
policies and opportunities
to change that construct.
So I wanted to commend you
for helping us think about
how clearly the way we behave,
and the way we treat each other,
and the way the policies kind
of define our social roles,
could actually unlock
tremendous potential.
And only by doing the type of research
that you are sharing today,
can we really unlock those keys.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, that's really important.
(applause)
It's very important research,
it's very important research.
And I really do wanna
emphasize that I think
a lot of the findings,
so this was a talk focused on gender.
But diversity is really the issue.
And a lot of the studies are looking at
diversity broadly measured.
And there's a fascinating study
that actually will be coming
out as a case at Haas,
based on a very large company sample,
and the very large company
sample is demonstrating
the diversity of the team,
these are team engagements,
really does affect both the profitability
of the engagement, and also
the quality of the engagement.
So better decisions,
more profitable outcomes.
Diversity really does matter.
And our social, so understanding
the cultural norms,
because, the reason I like
that table at the end so much
is because we need to be aware
of the social constructs
we're carrying around.
And we need to therefore,
once we know them,
we can maybe mentor a
woman to be a little more,
take a little more risk,
or we can encourage a CEO, no, no,
you actually do have to have a process
whereby you're transparent
in how you evaluate people,
you can't have this sort of difference
in negotiating style
affecting what you think
are meritocratic outcomes,
but they're not meritocratic outcomes,
they're something else.
So I think this is very important.
And I do think, so very
large global companies
are playing a very interesting role here,
because their markets
are all over the place,
and they're hiring talent
all over the place,
and they're selling all over the place,
so in many contexts,
all of those countries
that I mentioned that
are in the task force,
that is being driven by
their global companies,
or by global companies who are
operating in their countries.
Because they can see the business case
for themselves so clearly,
so in a way, once you can see
the case, or feel the case,
you can become a real leader here.
But great research.
I look forward to it.
Okay.
- Thank you, so to conclude,
it's my pleasure to
invite Esther and Harvey
up to the stage to personally thank Laura
for such an inspiring lecture.
- Well thank you.
(applause)
Ah, thank you guys.
It's so much fun to be with my students.
(laughs)
it's really lovely.
- We have this for you.
- Oh, thank you, thank you so much.
Great, wonderful.
All right, okay, thank you.
Where are they?
(applause)
Thank you so much, you guys.
It's so nice of you to do
this for the university.
(applause)
(light upbeat music)